Now, if you know the books,
chances are you know
the "Dear Friend" letters
between Yennefer and Geralt.
They are a moment of comedy
that really sums up
all the dysfunction
of the relationship.
They're very
funny but
not very romantic.
We don't see the letters in Season 2,
but we do get a nice nod toward them.
Let us take a look.
Geralt, do you know
what to do with this?
-Sorry.
-Ciri.
Sorry.
This is my...
You're so good in this.
...dear friend.
"Dear friend."
This is Yennefer.
You're Yennefer.
And you must be his...
Child Surprise.
Oh, you're so mean.
Yeah, to be fair, you don't
really have much right
-to be pissed off.
-Exactly.
You're... yeah, you're about
to try and kill my kid.
What did you call me?
Anya, Henry, and Freya,
in the books,
your characters have this
very tricky relationship,
as we saw,
and in the show it's the same.
Anya, you want
to sacrifice his kid,
you hold a knife
to her throat.
Like, how do you think
they feel about...
-Happy family!
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Saturday night in my house.
It's just like Monopoly, right?
Yeah, exactly.
How do you feel, like,
they feel about each other
at the end of the season?
-It's.. I mean...
-I don't know.
-It's tricky.
-It's a tricky one.
I mean, it's a fairly extreme
set of circumstances
to come back from.
I think we're... yeah,
we're gonna have
to play with that
-a little bit.
-I think we'll have
to figure that out
in Season 3, to be honest.
It's I mean,
it's pretty extreme,
so it's a tough one
to forgive.
It's gonna take
some real work
and some nuance
and some complexity...
All right, okay,
I've gotta work.
Yeah. So, Anya,
where do you see
your character going
in Season 3 and beyond?
It's habitual, isn't it?
She's how old,
and she's lived
the kind of life she's lived,
and, you know, the rules
that she lives by,
and that's Yen,
and she doesn't trust nobody,
and it's gonna be hard
to just delve into
a new way of being.
There are certain...
she might have learned
to consider things more,
but in the moment,
in such a kind of
violent world,
you know,
you've kind of just gotta
look out for yourself as well.
So, I don't know,
it's gonna be difficult.
I think whatever happens with
the storytelling in Season 3,
Anya's gonna knock it
out of the park.
She is extraordinary with
what she does with Yennefer.
The subtlety in her performance
is mind-blowing.
Like, you are top-notch.
Like what you see?
Be sure to check out
the full episode
of The Witcher: Unlocked,
the official Netflix Geeked
aftershow.